today we're testing nvidia's rtx 3090
this is their flagship gpu for the
current
30 series uh generation of gpus and a
gpu that they're saying is of titan
level of performance
but unlike titan cards nvidia have
allowed their aftermarket
sort of board partners to package them
with their aftermarket cooler designs
and that is something that might confuse
consumers
of what this card is actually meant to
do at 1500 us dollars this
is the most expensive gpu that i've had
on the test bench and it's the fastest
as well
as you could probably expect but if
you're after a high-end gaming gpu or a
high-end workstation gpu
how much better is this over the rtx
3080 is it
twice as good or at least 50 percent as
good let's take a look
[Music]
so let's dive in and take a look at
what's different versus the rtx
3080 that we've taken a look at over the
last week and which offered some
extremely good performance for the money
the 3090 offers a little over 20
more cuda cores rt cores and tensor
cores than the 3080
at a roughly similar boost clock on
paper the big difference here though is
the memory configuration
the 30 90 packs a mammoth 24 gigabytes
of gddr6
x memory with a max bandwidth edging
close to one terabyte per second the
total board power comes in at 350 watts
and all of that is on offer for 1500 us
dollars
now that sounds like a lot of money for
a gpu and don't get me wrong it
absolutely
is but let's put this into perspective
the titan rtx from last generation
came in at 2500 us and offers less
performance on paper at least
and when we compare it to the rtx 2080
ti the real difference between them is
only around 300 us dollars
and for that difference the 3090 offers
a ton more hardware under the hood
but it really is nvidia verse themselves
here because the question that we all
want to know as consumers
is how much better the rtx 3090 is over
the 3080
is it really worth over double the price
so the specific card that i have here
for testing is the rtx 3090 gaming
x trio from msi this is their flagship
design
as many of you know and unlike the 3080
this one has a completely metal
backplate with heat pipes
underneath and msi have really cleaned
up their design for this series the
gaming x trio looks exceptional
and you can expect a very quiet fan
curve out of the box
this card has a slightly higher power
limit and boost clock out of the box
compared to the founders edition
so keep that in mind when we look at the
performance and that is something that
we will be comparing because i do
actually have
the founders edition card right here and
yes it is
absolutely ginormous and it is the
biggest card that nvidia have ever
produced for a founder's edition card
i will have a dedicated video on this
one going up tomorrow so
make sure you are subscribed i also do
have the tough model from asus following
a few days after that
and from what we saw from their 3080
model i'd expect the performance here to
be
very good for now though let's just jump
right into the performance benchmarks
and
let's start off with the production
workloads first as opposed to starting
with gaming
because i do think that makes sense for
this gpu let's kick things
off with blender and here we're looking
at a 4k render at 500 samples per tile
and the 3090 beats the 3080 by 14.6
percent
and a little over a minute saved for
this particular scene
this was using cuda but let's see if
things improve when we switch over to
optics and actually they don't here the
3090 was just 13
faster than the 3080 and that's very
surprising given it costs over twice as
much
so if you have hundred dollars to put
towards gpu rendering performance in
your system
you'd actually be better off with two
rtx 3080s
theoretically you'd be doubling your
rendering performance and
beating the 3090 by almost 38
this is something that i do actually
plan to test in a future video
v-ray gives us slightly more promising
results though over 23 percent more
performance than the rtx 3080 but still
not what you'd expect for paying a
little over double
now for video editors don't expect much
faster performance when it comes to
export times or video stabilization
the only time that you really need to
upgrade to the 30 90 is for the
absolutely huge vram capacity of 24
gigabytes
and the use cases that need that amount
of vram are hard to test for
and usually highly specific for example
my own video editing demands do
sometimes exceed
the 11 gigabytes of vram on my rtx 2080
ti
that's usually when working with very
large projects on
a high resolution timeline while also
stabilizing a lot of footage
so that massive video memory capacity
would actually be
useful to me and i expect a lot of other
davinci resolve users working with
6k and 8k footage would say the same
thing we'll come back to this video
memory discussion but for now let's move
on to gaming
let's kick things off with a direct
comparison against the rtx 3080 in
red dead redemption 2 at 1440p and i
really mean it when i say that nvidia is
up against themselves here
the rtx 3080 not only looks exceptional
against gpus like the rtx 2080 and 2080
ti
but we're looking at a performance
margin of only 12 percent here between
it and the 3090. sure it's just 1440p
and we might see a slightly larger bump
at higher resolutions with the faster
memory configuration on the 3090
but 1440p is wildly more popular than 4k
and at 4k the 3090 is now almost 13
faster than the 3080 now able to exceed
over 200 fps in rainbow six siege
completely maxed out
so exceptional performance in a vacuum
but also
exceptionally poor value when compared
to the 3080 as a gaming gpu
and so far the rtx 3090 is looking like
a titan tier card in
the purest sense titan cards have
commonly been
marketed for production workloads and
their very large memory capacities and
have never
really offered outstanding gaming
performance margins over the top tier
gaming cards
underneath them in fact in star wars
jedi fall in order there's only an
eight percent performance margin between
it and the 3080 and that's typically a
margin that you could close with a beefy
overclock
what i find interesting here is when you
remove the 3080
from these graphs the 3090 looks
exceptional when compared to the 1200
2080 ti there you're getting almost a 50
performance increase versus a 25
increase in price and that's actually
extremely good value when you're looking
at this tier of gpu but with the 30 80
thrown into the mix the 3090
is a hard sell in shadow of the tomb
raider again completely maxed out at 4k
we see another 12 performance margin in
favor of the rtx 3090
and look i'm not expecting double the
performance for basically double the
price no one expects that when you're
talking about top tier gpus
but i think most of us expected at least
over the 30 80 after all that's roughly
what you get with a 2080 ti
over at 2080. so the 3090 is no doubt
the fastest gaming gpu that we've seen
but with consistent performance margins
of as little as 13
it's barely a perceivable difference
over the rtx 3080.
again the 3080 is the real party crasher
here the 3090 is an insanely fast gpu
on its own but it's almost as if nvidia
made the 3080
too fast there was one interesting game
benchmark between these two gpus though
and that's battlefield 5.
here we're looking at 4k ultra settings
and again
the 3090 leads by 13 but the 3090 is the
only gpu
in this title that i've tested that has
shown consistent stable frame rate
performance
the real-time fps graphs at the top show
this clearly
with the 3090 having no small frequent
dips in frame rate which
by the way aren't really perceivable on
the 3080 only with
lower end cards f1 2020 showed the
largest performance lead for the rtx
a 15.7 percent increase over the 30 80.
that gets stretched to 16.1 when we
factor in
dlss for both gpus with both delivering
well over 144 fps at 4k
now it's hard to complain about gaming
performance here when nvidia have
clearly stated that the 3080 is the
gaming flagship gpu
and not the 3090. and looking at the
results
it's pretty clear why they said that
lastly we have control with the smallest
difference between
these two gpus that i've tested at
around 10 in both pure rasterization
performance
and when factoring in ray tracing and
dlss here we're looking at the game at
4k
completely maxed out and that's enough
to reduce both gpus to under 60 fps
both the 3080 and 3090 get a small boost
when factoring in ray tracing and dlss
and at this point the 3090 is just able
to edge over an average of 60 fps
clock speeds for the msi gaming x trio
variant of the rtx 3090 have it settling
in at around 1900 megahertz which is
only 30 megahertz less than what we saw
with the 3080 of the same card and
cooler design
nvidia do list a slightly lower boost
clock for the 30 90 compared to the 3080
so this is what you would expect
the gaming x trio has decent thermal
performance from what we can see so far
although i haven't compared it to
anything just yet so do stay tuned for
the follow up reviews with the founders
edition and asus tough
for comparison as we saw with the 3080
gaming x trio this card has a quiet fan
curve which runs a little bit on the
warmer end
settling in at 75 degrees c with the gpu
fans at around 1450 rpm
power consumption is 44 watts over the
30 80 when tested in control at 4k
that's not a significant amount but it's
likely going to be enough to push
600 watt power supplies over the edge in
more cpu intensive games i will note
that i'm also planning some
in-depth content on overclocking and
under vaulting both the 3080 and 3090
and what effect that has on power
thermals and overall performance but
that definitely requires its own entire
video
so on one hand it's hard to complain
about the gaming performance compared to
the 3080 when nvidia didn't
initially position the 3090 as a gpu for
gamers
at least with the initial announcement
but then at the same time
recently really pushing this as a gpu
that's capable of 8k
gaming i feel it's a bit misleading now
i have absolutely no problem saying that
yes the rtx 3090 could probably game at
8k
resolution if you do have an 8k tv or an
8k monitor which
is probably very few of you i'm guessing
but the problem is that if this is now
an 8k gaming gpu and kind of people see
the marketing headlines and sponsored
content around 8k
gaming people think that okay if this
thing can do 8k
gaming it can probably absolutely crush
4k gaming and 1440p resolution gaming
in reality it's only 12 to 14 faster
than the 3080
in those resolutions so i would have
liked to see a clear cut in the
marketing as to what this gpu
actually is is it a gaming gpu or a
production workload gpu with a ton of
vram
in the end who should buy the rtx 3090
well if your computer makes you money
and you frequently encounter video
memory limitations in your current
workflow
the 3090 is the single fastest gpu to
chew through whatever it is you do i
have no doubt that there are
scientists researchers and 3d artists
out there who are rejoicing at a
lower cost titan equivalent gpu with a
huge
24 gigabytes of gddr6x memory to play
with
but for the same price maybe also
consider two rtx 3080s especially if you
use something like blender or octane
render which
both do have excellent multi gpu support
that would be the most effective way to
spend around fifteen hundred dollars
towards
gpu rendering performance and i do
understand that some workloads don't
scale as well or
at all with multi gpu support so there
is a case for the 3090 if you are
willing to pay as much as it is
so i'll leave some links down below in
the description if you're interested in
the 3080 or the 3090 although
don't expect stock to be there just
right now definitely check back in a
couple weeks or so
as always a huge thanks for watching
plenty of content out around the corner
as you can see
we do also have the rtx 3080 founders
edition which nvidia kindly sent over
and there will be tons of content coming
up on these two cards here
so as always a huge thanks for watching
and i will see you all
in the next one